torres protection team checked in on
schedule
all as well
actress charles b dean has died
she was 32.
[Music]
tmz reports the south african
entertainer died of an unexpected and
sudden illness on monday
no further details are known
the up-and-coming star made a splash
earlier this year at the cannes film
festival
she attended the lavish event to promote
triangle of sadness her first big screen
lead role
he looks paid for the tickets not better
that's what you do
she played a model named yaya starring
alongside woody harrelson
i don't think that's possible man
because this is a motorized vessel
the film which follows passengers aboard
a wrecked cruise ship is slated to hit
theaters on october 7th this is really
bad
this is really really bad but before
that charle b was known for her role as
cyanide on the cw's black lightning
[Music]
and she made smaller appearances in
films like wedding swingers
i uh don't know any of you very well
but it's uh really nice to have you here
cheryl b was also successful in her
modeling career getting photographed for
british vogue gq cosmopolitan and more
even working with victoria's secret i
think korea defining jobs
as a model is often victoria's secret
working with them has been really nice
and just
great to travel to those beaches and be
around a crew that's kind of like a
family
charlie is survived by her fiance model
luke volcker the two got engaged in
april
she's also remembered by her parents and
brother alexi
who shared a lengthy poem on instagram
in his sister's memory alongside a black
and white photo and the words may heaven
be all you ever imagined
[Music]
you